let's just bring you some breaking news  that's coming in regarding the queen and  that is that the queen has held her  first in-person engagement since  catching covid  meeting canadian prime minister justin  trudeau the monarch held an audience  with mr trudeau this afternoon um at  windsor castle uh mr trudeau is in the  uk of course as we mentioned earlier on  for talks with the um uk prime minister  boris johnson and also with the top  dutch prime minister  mark rutter and that's due to take place  later on this afternoon at 10 to 3 this  afternoon so that's the latest that's  just coming in now as you can see the  the queen holding her first in-person  engagement since catching covid and that  is with canadian prime minister justin  trudeau earlier at windsor castle